The following
content is provided
under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue
to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation, or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: I apologize
for the delay.
But we are ready
for multimedia show
with three different
applications.
One of them are the clickers.
I hope you all took a clicker.
It's just two questions today,
but really good questions.
[LAUGHTER]
So today's actually
very nice topic.
I think almost every lecture
we have a nice topic,
but today's especially nice.
It's called Unraveling
Open Quantum System.
That may not tell you so much.
Well unravelling means we
want to sort of untangle it,
We want to understand
what is inside.
And so we want to develop
a better understanding what
is inside a density matrix.
How can we think about
the quantum system
in an even more microscopic
way than the density
matrix tell us?
And again, this finds
applications in atomic physics,
because one application of it
is spontaneous emission optical
block equations.
On the other hand,
actually, this class
will also teach you
something very general
about quantum physics.
So today's lecture is this part.
We'll have three topics.
One is I want to provide a
motivation for single quantum
systems.
And you should appreciate this.
A single quantum system is not
what Schrodinger and Heisenberg
told us about.
Quantum mechanics was formulated
as an ensemble average.
But today we want to talk about,
is there something in addition?
About single quantum systems.
Part two is-- addresses the
derivation of the quantum Monte
Carlo wave function method.
And this is a formalism,
which is really
simulating in quite general
terms, quantum physics
by following-- using quantum
Monte Carlo simulations--
trajectories of individual
quantum systems.
So here the individual
quantum system--
even if you have one, even
if you don't have one--
becomes a computational tool.
And eventually in
part two I want
to give you another example
for unraveling open quantum
system, which differ from
the models for dephasing.
And if you remember that this
was on one of your homework
assignment that's correct.
I sort of want to here
take your homework
into the classroom discussion.
Well I think it's nice to start
this lecture with the quote
by Erwin Schrodinger.
Where he said, "We
never experiment
with just one electron,
or atom, or molecule.
In thought experiments, we
sometimes assume that we do;
this inevitably entails
ridiculous consequences."
Well today we want to talk about
those ridiculous consequences,
because many people
in our field trap,
address, and observe single
electrons and single atoms.
Now this is related
to quantum jumps.
Quantum jumps has even made
it into the popular realm.
You can find lots and lots of
references on quantum jumping,
but I warn you this
is about quantum
jumping into different worlds.
It's about broadening
your horizon.
And those authors,
those people actually,
sell you something by claiming
that people like Einstein
and Stephen Hawking would
support the idea that you can
jump into different universe,
experience another version
of yourself-- probably a
better version of yourself--
and this will
inspire you to change
your life in the world you live.
But-- So this is
quantum jumping.
I'm not talking about
quantum jumping,
I will only talk
about quantum chunks.
So what you see here is
really a classic experiment.
One of three
experiments which were
done almost simultaneously.
There have always been
races for, you know,
the first observation
of something.
And there was the [? Hamburg ?]
group by [? Toshak ?],
the Seattle group
by Hunt [INAUDIBLE],
and the Boulder
Group by Dave Wylen,
who observed the phenomenon
of quantum jumps for the first
time.
Let me just tell you
what it is, because it's
exactly what you're
going to describe.
Here in this situation
you have a system.
It's a trapped barium
ion with a p and s state.
And there is very
fast transition
where you can rapidly
scatter light, and get
lots of fluorescence,
at 493 nanometer.
But what happened is,
every once in a while,
the particle has a branching
ratio to decay to d state,
and, well, d to s 2 units
of angular momentum.
The transition here down to
the ground state is very slow.
It's slow because
it's forbidden.
It's even slower
because it happens
at longer wavelengths
of 1,600 nanometer.
And this is slow.
And it has a lifetime
of about 50 second.
So you-- If you think
about it naively
and that's probably
the correct approach--
you would say the
particles in the s state,
it's like a light bulb.
It scatters many, many
photons, but then it
branches to the d state.
And for 50 seconds
the light bulb
is switched off, until
the particle spontaneously
goes down to the s state,
and then the light bulb
is switched on.
And this is exactly
what people observed.
But I mean I was-- This was '86.
That was the time I
was a graduate student,
and I talked with
theorists in the field,
and respectable
theorists told me
that there was a
controversy-- probably
not among experimentalists,
who use the naive
approach-- but theorists
who believed too much
in what they calculate.
Because if you solve it
quantum mechanically,
and look what you get.
It's a steady state solution.
Atom in steady state.
Laser in steady state.
And if you calculate the quantum
mechanical expectation value,
the expectation value is
constant as a function of time.
So a simple quantum
calculation would
say the fluorescence
is on average.
Well just the time
average and his constant,
and his time independent.
So there were some
serious doubts
whether you would observe
this, or something
which looks more like
the ensemble average.
Well made all of the theorists
soon realize you cannot
calculate the steady
state average.
You have to calculate
the correlation function
in steady state.
And the steady state
correlation function
has structure exactly
at 50 seconds.
So in a steady state
system, if you're
interested in fluctuations
and temporal behavior,
you can't just
calculate quantities,
you have to calculate
correlation functions
of quantities.
So anyway-- But then
of course, if you now
average over many,
many realizations,
you find exactly an exponential
decay of 50 seconds.
And this is sort
of what you would
get for an ensemble average.
So this is what
quantum jumps are.
This is what you
should always imagine
when we talk about quantum jumps
in the rest of this lecture.
But I also want to show
you more recent example
from Serge Haroche,
in Paris, where
they observed quantum jumps.
Recording a single
photon in a cavity.
So what happens is there's a
single photon in this cavity,
and they can read
out whether there
is a photon or not by sending
Rydberg atoms through.
And a single photon
is never observed,
but it causes a phase
shift, an AC-Stark shift,
on the Rydberg atom.
And then they can read out
with a Ramsey interferometer
the AC-Stark shift.
So every atom which
passes through the cavity
will tell you whether
there is a photon or not.
And-- And this is shown here.
Blue means no,
there is no photon.
Red means there is a photon.
So here you repeatedly figure
out again there is no photon.
And suddenly there
is a quantum jump
when the cavity has
absorbed a photon,
or when a thermal
photon was released.
You may say, what happened here?
Well no measurement is perfect.
There is some noise.
But by seeing that
these are outliers,
you clearly see that here
is a photon in the cavity,
and here where the red
read out of the atom
overwhelms the blue readout
here you have no photon.
And then as time goes by, you
can observe the death and birth
of micro-cavity photons.
So these are now quantum
jumps in the-- not
in atomic population, but
quantum jumps in the photon
number in a cavity.
AUDIENCE:What's the
time scale on that?
Seconds?
PROFESSOR: Yeah, time is second.
So what is shown here is-- I
think what is shown is here
are 300 milliseconds, and
this is 2.5 second element.
AUDIENCE: What was the
density of each line mean?
PROFESSOR: Each line
is a Rydberg atom,
which has been readout with
a Ramsey interferometer.
And--
AUDIENCE: So that
means that they're
leaving no, like between--
PROFESSOR: I think
that means there
was a Rydberg atom in state e,
which means there is a photon.
And blue means, the
blue bar means, there
was a Rydberg atom in state g.
These are two highlighting
states of the rubidium atom.
Sort of each spike
here is one readout
of the microchannel plate.
So these are detector clicks.
You can say, yes.
You can sort of say, blue
is yes, and red is no.
And these are the two clicks.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, but, like the
separation between two clicks
is not uniform.
PROFESSOR: No, because
if you're an atomic beam
the atoms come not
equally spaced out.
There's a randomness
when the atom comes.
I think it's posed only in
statistics in this experiment.
It's a real experiment.
It's amazing.
Other questions?
Team One.
AUDIENCE: So one more question.
So the, for example,
the first bit of blue
is all measurements for the
same state of the cavity.
I know blue means
photon or no photon,
but if it does mean
photon, that means
it's the same photon
interacting with--
PROFESSOR: Yes.
AUDIENCE: OK.
PROFESSOR: Yes, because, I
mean, this is something people
know that the photon
number in this cavity
only changes over
very long time scales.
And you sort of see,
kind of, exactly
hear how-- You see
here two quantum jumps.
One from blue to
red, and one from red
to blue in this cavity.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: I don't if
this is maybe just
my accent's not very good,
but in the bottom left graph--
Right?
Or on the bottom graph, in
sort of the left corner,
it looks like
there's some overlap
between the dark blue
and the dark red.
Yeah.
PROFESSOR: You mean here?
AUDIENCE: Yeah,
like right there.
Is that like sort of there is
a photon in that [INAUDIBLE]
simultaneously?
PROFESSOR: I think, to
the best of my knowledge,
I haven't really
looked-- I've heard
wonderful talks about it.You
can go back and read the paper,
but this probably means in
the atom number in the cavity,
and the algorithm they have
used to analyze the data
says that here the photon
number was 0, jumped to 1,
and jumped back again.
So you-- If you see
here, for instance,
there is some overlap,
but you would still
say, since either there is
a photon or not a photon,
as long as you have a--
as you have a higher
number of red clicks
than blue clicks,
you would say there is a photon.
And the little overlap, there
is maybe a little bit of time
where you don't know whether
there is a photon or not.
But this really-- This is
real, because every measurement
takes a certain amount of time.
Since you have a
few random clicks,
if they are a few
random clicks, you
do not know yet if
the system has jumped,
you have to wait a little bit.
But this is really
also showing how
our knowledge about the
quantum system comes with time.
And therefore,
the wave function,
or the statistical
operator changes with time,
because of wave function
and statistical operator
are simply a description of
our knowledge about the quantum
system.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
is too dense
PROFESSOR: You could have
a situation, for instance,
you could prepare
the cavity, that it
has an equal probability
foreseeable in one.
And then what you would read out
may just be completely random.
So that may be possible,
but in their experiment,
I think, the nature
here is that you
have most of the
time stable photons,
because the cavity is cooled
to very low temperature,
and only occasionally does
the thermal distribution,
the Bose-Einstein distribution
of photons in the cavity
have a one.
And what we observe are
the thermal fluctuations
between mainly 0 and
occasionally a 1.
If you would make the cavity
and little bit hotter,
it would have maybe
half of the time a 1
and half of the time 0.
But that wouldn't mean that
you have completely randomness
in your results, because
there is a thermal relaxation
time over which a
photon is created,
and a photon goes back.
The photon would not jump
back and forth from the cavity
to the walls of the
cavity in microseconds.
It would probably
have an exchange time,
and you could sort of measure
the thermal correlation
time of photons in a cavity.
It's a really good experiment.
OK.
So in that sense I
think I showed you
that what Schrodinger said
is ridiculous is real,
is the subject of
current research,
and since for
quantum information
processing in
quantum computers, we
need single quantum system
is at the heart of quantum
information processing.
So therefore, we
want to now describe
single quantum systems.
But when I do that,
I-- come very --
It will become clear at
the end of this unit,
but I want to give you
the warning right away.
The way how I describe now
a single quantum system
may not be unique.
There will be,
there is actually,
an infinite number of ways.
And I've already
mentioned that to you,
that there is an
infinite number of ways
to unravel a density matrix.
I mentioned that you can
write every density matrix
as a probability of pure states.
Weighted probability of
being in pure states,
but there's always
different choices.
You can get an infinite number
of different combinations
of pure states, and construct
your density matrix.
So, so this was sort of in
at the level of the density
matrix, but similarly--
and this will come out
of this discussion today--
there is also an infinite number
of ways to unravel the
dynamics-- the dynamics
involved in the evolution
of an open quantum system.
So-- so with that I want to
describe the quantum Monte
Carlo wave function method.
So in the quantum Monte
Carlo wave function method,
we perform-- We don't
need an experiment.
We don't need
sophisticated experiments
to observe a single
quantum system.
It's a theoretical
method, but we
perform thought, or
gedanken experiments.
So our gedanken experiments is
that we perform measurements.
So we assume-- we
have-- When we want
to describe an
ensemble of atoms,
we assume we have a single atom.
We assume it emits
photon, and then we
assume that the
photon is detected.
And the mom-- So the
moment the photon
is detected we
know, for instance,
that the atom is in
the ground state.
And so our quantum Monte
Carlo simulation follows now
the trajectory of the single
quantum system by saying,
I toss a coin, there's
a certain probability
for detecting the photon.
If I detect the photon,
the system I know
is in the ground state.
If I don't detect
the photon, it's
not in the ground
state, and such.
And these probabilistic
approach is just simulated
in the quantum
Monte Carlo sense.
So-- So what is
in essence-- what
is the essence of the
quantum Monte Carlo
method is that we allow a
small time step delta t.
It's a real time simulation.
And there is a small
probability that the system
has decayed in that time.
So we may now toss a coin-- use
a random function generator--
and ask, has spontaneous
emission taken place?
And then the two
possibilities are yes,
and we continue
whatever the outcome,
whatever the quantum state is.
Or we say no, and then with
the probability-- with a-- so
with a probability,
p, we say yes.
With a probability
1 minus p we say no,
and then we continue the
simulation accordingly.
So this will become
much, much clearer
when I write down the
formalism for you,
but there is one important
aspect, which I really
want to discuss with you.
And this is the
essence of the method.
Namely, how does
the wave function
change by your measurement?
So-- so this is the essential,
the only conceptional part
for the quantum Monte
Carlo wave function.
Afterwards I just show you.
Once you have this,
once we have cleared up
this conceptional part, the
rest is just a few equations.
And we immediately show that
the quantum Monte Carlo wave
function method is equivalent
to the optical block equation.
But let's really feature
and take some time
for discussing the concept,
namely, the change over wave
function by a
quantum measurement.
And maybe what this
carries home to you
is that the nature of an open
system-- we have a quantum
system, which interacts
with the environment--
is, actually, that the
environment permanently
performs measurements.
And you will actually see
that the idea of performing
measurements, formalized in
the quantum Monte Carlo sense,
gives us an equation for
the density matrix, which
is identical to the
optical block equation.
So in other words, you
can say I am re-deriving
for you master equation now,
but from a very, very different
perspective.
From the perspective
of an environment
which constantly
performs measurement.
OK.
So let's go through that.
How-- What happens
in a measurement?
Well if our initial state is
the ground state-- starting
very in trivial ways-- well
there is no measurement,
because the particle will stay
in the ground state forever.
OK.
Now let's go to
the next situation
that our atom starts out
in the excited state.
Now in a time step delta t,
we have two possibilities.
A photon can be observed,
or nor photon is observed.
When the photon is
observed, we know for sure
that the system is now
projected into the ground state.
If no photon is
observed, well the system
is still in the excited state.
OK.
So we've discussed what happens
when the system is initially
in the ground, and when
the system is initially
in the excited state.
But now comes the
following question.
We prepare the system
in a superposition
of ground and excited state.
And we want to
discuss what happens
when the photon is observed?
What happens when no
photon is observed?
I think if you observe
the photon it's
pretty clear we have to
assume after photon emission
the system is in
the ground state.
But if no photon is observed, I
want to give you three choices,
and you should address
them with the clicker.
One choice is that the particle
stays in the same state.
The second choice is
that the particle stays
in a superposition state,
but the probability
to be in the excited
state decays.
Also no photon
has being emitted,
or no photon has been observed.
And the third possibility
is something else.
So in other words, assume
you're an observer,
and you know with 100%
detection probability--
let's not discuss technical
issues-- you have completely
surrounded your system
with perfect detectors.
And you know in the time
step delta t, in the time t,
no photon was observed.
And now you should
make a prediction
what happens next to
the quantum system.
And you make the
prediction by assuming
that the system is described
by a wave function or density
matrix.
And I'm asking you, which
of the three choices
correctly describes what the
system will do afterwards?
What the system will do next?
Is the question very clear?
Good.
[TAPPING]
OK.
All right.
Pretty good.
A lot of people when I taught
the class before said it's A,
the wave function
is not changing,
because no photon
has been emitted.
Now in-- For those people, but
there only few among those,
I would have now asked
the next question.
If you have-- If you have
a 50-50 superposition,
of ground and excited
state-- And let's
say the spot time for
spontaneous emission
is 10 nanoseconds-- But
now you wait one second,
and after 1 second, no
photon has been observed.
What is your prediction?
In what state is the
system at this point?
Is the system in
the ground state?
Or is the system in,
still in, a superposition
of ground and excited state?
Well since we have to
clicker, you can tell me.
Is it-- Is it still a
superposition state,
or is the system in
the ground state?
OK.
So now you have to help me out,
because the people who said B,
if they would go back to
here-- And most people said
it is B. If you put in gamma 10
nanoseconds, the inverse of 10
nanosecond, and the
time is 1 second,
the excited state amplitude,
the excited stated mixture,
is 10 to the minus nothing.
So-- OK.
If you want to be a
mathematician and say--
[LAUGHING]
--there is epsilon 10
to the minus 10, yes.
Then you can say there is
still a small admixture
to the excited state.
But by making it so
extreme-- 10 nanoseconds
versus a second-- at least
in all practical terms,
the system is in
the ground state.
And I think this
should teach you
what it means if you
have a system which
is in the superposition of
ground and excited state,
and after 1 second it
has not emitted a photon.
I mean--
Then you would say,
it had its chance.
It had plenty of
chances to emit,
but it decided it
doesn't want to emit.
And that would mean
your 50/50 superposition
of ground and
excited state means
the atom decided that
it's in the ground state.
You should also realize
a 50% superposition
of ground and
excited state means
in half, in 50% of the
cases there will never
be a photon emitted.
So in other words,
what you should realize
is if your 50-50% superposition
of ground and excited state,
that the quantum
evolution of this system
is-- after a long
time the system
is definitely positively,
absolutely in the ground state.
It's always in the ground
state after a long time.
In 50% of the cases with
emission of a photon,
in 50% of the cases without
emission of a photon.
If you have a
radioactive-- ensemble
of radioactive nuclei-- and
let's say half of the atoms
are in the excited state
and [INAUDIBLE] and half are
in the ground state-- and you
send the sample to your friend,
and your friend waits many,
many, many half times,
common sense tells you that
all the particles are now
in the ground state.
Also only half of them have
decayed, because the other half
were in the ground
state to begin with.
I mean this is what
quantum physics tells us.
This is what a 50/50
superposition is.
But quantitatively
this is, of course,
included in this
result-- which magically
that almost all of you
got right-- namely there
is a superposition of
ground and excited state,
but the excited state
amplitude decays.
And to the limit, in the limit
that the time is much longer
than the decay time, no matter
what the coefficient initially
was in front of
the excited state,
this coefficient
has decayed to 0.
Any question about that?
Let me just
emphasize that, again
in giving you also an example in
the reference, a 0 measurement.
A 0 measurement modifies
the wave function.
You can also put it like this,
what the wave function is
is the best knowledge you
would have about this system.
The wave function is a way
to predict what happens next,
and it's the most precise
way to predict it.
More accurate predictions than
the wave function always cannot
be made, because of Heisenberg's
uncertainty relation.
But what happens is,
if you have a 50/50%
superposition of ground
and excited state,
and the system has not emitted,
then you would say initially
my guess was half of the atoms
were excited, half of the atoms
are in the ground state.
But if none of them
has decayed for awhile,
you would say I revise
my estimate now.
Now I have to assume that
more are in the ground state.
Because having not decayed means
there is a higher probability
that the system has actually--
is in the ground state
to begin with.
So this is how this way of
dealing with a wave function
automatically adjusts
for the knowledge
you have gained
about the system.
Let me give you another
example which carries home
the same message, and I take
it from a pedagogical paper
from Dickey, from American
Journal of Physics, 49, 926,
1981.
And what he discussed
is the following.
You have a box and originally
your atomic wave function
is completely localized.
Your Bose-Einstein condensate
if you want in this box,
or let's just assume one
atom to be more precise,
and it's completely delocalized.
But now you focus a laser
beam into the system.
And the laser beam
would ionize your atom,
and you could count the
ion with 100% probability.
And for a short moment,
you flash on the laser
and the result is
yes, you count.
You get a count.
In that moment you
would say my wave
function is more localized.
I revise my estimate.
Well maybe I
shouldn't say ionized.
If it's ionized you
destroy the atom.
Let's just say you observe
fluorescence so the atom is
still alive.
But now you have to
say that the atom is
localized in that region.
However, if you don't
observe anything,
you would say, well
now it's actually
more probable that
the atom is outside.
Because if it had been
in the laser beam,
with a certain probability, I
would have detected a photon.
But the non-detection
of a photon
means that I revise my estimate.
And I say it's
much more probable
that the atom is
outside the laser beam
than inside the laser beam.
So this here is exactly how a
non-observation of anything,
a 0 measurement, modifies
your wave function.
And the formalism
to incorporate that
is what we have
discussed before.
Yes?
Cody?
AUDIENCE: So your arguments
here so far work the same way
as if it's in a
wave function, you
have just an entire
Pascal probability,
and we're updating our
understanding of probability.
Like you haven't
included anything
about the relative phase
between these two--
PROFESSOR: I want
to do that now.
I mean, I-- This is sort of just
to address the basic concepts
about what does a
measurement mean,
what does a 0 measurement mean.
But now I want to write
down everything for you
in amplitudes.
We want to do exactly the
time evolution of the system.
Nancy?
AUDIENCE: Is this,
like, inconsistent
with [INAUDIBLE]
quantum equation?
Like especially the [INAUDIBLE],
because when you are saying
that it is admixture of the
ground and excited state,
and we did not observe--
PROFESSOR: Then
the superposition
say that ground
and excited state.
We are not starting out in
an energy heightened state,
so therefore, we--
what we have is not
a sharp value of the energy,
but an expectation value.
And also if you repeat
the measurement many,
many times, the average
energy is conserved,
and this is exactly what energy
conservation in quantum physics
says.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Well if your
particle, if your system,
is not in an eigenstate
of the Hamiltonian.
It doesn't have a sharp energy.
And that would mean that when
you measure the energy now,
you have fluctuations.
Sometimes you measure higher,
sometimes you measure lower.
It's only when
you're in eigenstate
that you measure a sharp value.
And therefore you know
from the beginning
that you will measure
an energy distribution.
And sometimes you
measure higher,
and sometimes you measure
lower than the average value.
There's nothing wrong
about it, but your question
is a very good one.
You should-- I
mean those examples
are really-- On the one
hand they are trivial,
but on the other hand, it's
very profound what they tell us
about quantum physics
and how to apply
conservation laws and such.
OK.
I think-- Let's-- Let me now
formalize exactly how this is
done with all the
bells and whistles.
We assume we have an initial
wave function, which is now
an arbitrary superposition state
of ground and excited state.
And we have the environment,
which, in this case,
we assume is the 0 photon state.
It's a vacuum.
And we want to exactly
solve the Schrodinger
equation for that system.
But we restrict
ourselves too much,
to a very small time step.
The small time step is smaller
than, you know, anything else.
Than the natural decay time.
Maybe the inverse
[INAUDIBLE] frequency
if you drive the system.
You're not doing it
here, but I will later
show how you can add a laser
beam and drive the system.
Or it should also be smaller
than the inverse tuning.
So what is very important here
is that we want to deal only
with simple cases,
namely one photon
has been emitted or not photon.
So you want to make
sure that there
is, at most, one
spontaneous emission event
during the time delta t.
So what I'm writing down now
is the total wave function
of the system plus
the environment.
And now we can evolve it.
We can ask what happens?
What is the wave
function time later?
This can be exactly done by
time-dependent perturbation
theory.
And the result is
that the system
will be in a superposition
of ground and excited state.
And we want to calculate
the coefficients
alpha prime and beta prime.
And we still have
the vacuum state.
But then we have the possibility
that a photon has been emitted.
In that case we are
in the ground state.
And the direct product
with the environment
involves now the photon emitted
into a certain direction
with wave vector k, with
the polarization epsilon.
And we have coefficients
beta, k epsilon,
and we have to sum over all
possibilities for the photon
to be emitted.
So we call this-- So the wave
function of the total system
has now two parts.
It's a wave function,
which I call psi 0.
This is a wave
function which involves
no photon in the environment.
And the wave function
psi 1 involves
one photon in the environment.
So this is the [INAUDIBLE],
which seems very natural,
but it's also-- you
could immediately
prove that these are the
only possibilities, how
the system can evolve.
And we can verify this by using
time-dependent perturbation
theory.
It's actually almost
everyone of you
has seen it in either 8.21 or in
a more basic course on quantum
physics.
It's time-dependent
perturbation theory
for the emission of a photon.
But usually when you see
those treatments there
reservoir, the environment,
is not treated as explicitly
as we do it here.
The theory where this
is treated exactly
in this way, how we need it,
is the Viegener Biscoff theory.
Which is nothing else in
the perturbative approach,
but it's really a
perturbation theory.
Not just for the atomic system--
how we sometimes present it
in a simplified version--
it's perturbation theory
for the total wave function
of the complete system.
Philmore?
AUDIENCE: So you mentioned
the time interval [INAUDIBLE]
is much smaller than
a lot of things.
But you were ignoring, I take
it, the counter rotating terms?
In which case we're still
at a large enough time
step that's average
out, so to speak?
I simply say this,
because I expected
to be an e with a photon term.
From the g going
up, so to speak.
PROFESSOR: Yes.
Well-- The counter
rotating term--
The first answer I
wanted to give you,
no this is exact
perturbation theory.
But I think I get
myself in trouble
if I would allow-- I would get
myself in trouble if I would
allow the time step to be
extremely short, because then
I'm in shorter
than 1 over omega.
Because during the
time 1 over omega,
we have-- you can say we
have counter rotating terms.
Or in other words, this
particle in the ground
state during a
time 1 over omega,
particle in the ground state can
emit a photon and reabsorb it.
These are where
those weird diagrams
with virtual states,
which we discussed earlier
in this course.
So I think I want to assume
here, which I haven't done,
that the time step is larger
than omega to the minus 1.
And as you know the
counter rotating term
has a detuning delta,
which is 2 omega,
so therefore it is excluded.
Or in other words, when
we talk about photons
sent into the
environment, we want
to talk about real photons,
and not virtual photons.
Yes, good point.
OK.
So if you do simple lowest order
time dependent perturbation
theory, in the Viegener
Biscoff approach,
you get an exact
result for beta prime.
You find that beta prime
in this superposition
is the original amplitude
beta, but it has decayed with e
to the minus gamma over 2dt.
And since we are only
interested in small time steps,
we can do a linear
expansion of that.
The probability, dp, that
a photon has been emitted
is the norm of this
wave function psi 1.
And this, using Viegener
Biscoff perturbation theory,
is gamma dt times the
amplitude squared,
that the system was
excited to begin with.
And because of the conservation
of the norm, the wave function,
the norm of the wave
function psi 0-- which
is a wave function without
a photon being emitted--
is 1 minus dp.
So what I'm telling
you here is that this
is an exact result of
time-dependent perturbation
theory.
Often when this-- when textbooks
treat spontaneous emission,
they're more interested
in getting Fermi's gold
rule at this rate.
But the same approach-- if
you just write it down--
tells you how the amplitude
in the excited state evolves.
So therefore, what we learn
from perturbation theory,
that alpha prime and beta prime,
the wave, the coefficients
of the wave function,
without emission of a photon,
this evolution of
the wave function
occurs with a
non-emission Hamiltonian.
And this non-emission
Hamiltonian
is our Hamiltonian
for the atomic system.
But then we have to account
for spontaneous decay,
and this is done by
this non-emission part.
So occasionally
you may have heard
that people wave
their hands and say,
your system is described
by a Hamiltonian, which
has an imaginary part for decay.
And this is sort of
phenomenological.
This is definitely not
the case, because, even
if you have a
Hamiltonian like this,
a pure state would simply
decay and remain a pure state.
What we are doing
here explicitly
is we deal with probability
in the correct way.
Every time the
system can branch out
into different possibilities,
two different dimensions
of the density matrix-- one
has probability delta p,
one has probability
1 minus delta p--
and it is only the wave
function associated
with probability 1
minus delta p, which
evolves with this Hamiltonian.
So what I'm telling you
is the exact solution
for the evolution
of the total system,
in terms of a density matrix
for the atomic system.
And this is exact.
So that means we
can now-- write down
the-- Just get some extra space.
Oops.
How does it do it?
Nope So we have to
insert new page.
Yep.
OK.
So the procedure, how we
implement this exact solution
of perturbation theory,
is the following.
We have a time step delta t.
We compute what
is the probability
that a photon will be emitted.
Then we need a ran-- Then we
need a random number generator.
So we need a number
epsilon, which
is a random number chosen
in the interval 0 and 1.
If this random number turns
out to be smaller than delta p,
then we continue our time
evolution on the computer.
That psi is now in
the ground state,
and maybe there is a laser
beam which excites it again.
And such I will add a few
bells and whistles later.
Otherwise psi,
our wave function,
is now the wave function
which is the time evolution
with a non-emission operator of
the original wave function psi.
And since we have a
real wave function now
with probability 1, we have to
re-normalize the wave function
by this denominator.
And then we execute
the next time step.
This means go to 2 and
do the next time step.
And then you have, so to speak,
if you do it many, many times,
you get a time direct
trajectory of, so to speak,
one experiment.
And then you start again with
your system in a wave function
psi, and you accumulate
a second experiment.
And maybe you do it 10,000
times to get enough statistics.
And then you sum up,
you know, everything
you want and calculate
all the expectation
values you want to know
about your quantum system.
So the claim is that this
method, called quantum Monte
Carlo wave function
method, is fully
equivalent to the
optical block equations.
And I want to prove
it to you by showing
that, if I take a density
matrix, which is an ensemble
average, over many
realizations of those quantum
Monte Carlo trajectories.
That then this density matrix
follows the differential
equation, which is your
optical block equation.
And the proof is shown here.
So what I told you is the
density matrix after time delta
t, has now two matrix elements.
One with probability
delta p, and this
is-- photon has been emitted.
System is in the ground state,
with probability 1 minus delta
p.
We evolve the quantum state
with a non-emission Hamiltonian.
And then all what is done
in the next few steps we
assume that delta t is small.
We do a Taylor expansion
of the exponent.
We neglect quadratic
terms in delta t,
and then we come to this line.
And if we write this as
rho of t plus delta t,
minus the original
rho of t, we find
that this follows differential
equation, which is exactly
the optical block equations.
So therefore what we
sort of implemented
as a form of doing many,
many quantum measurements
in the environment
is a procedure,
which is rigorously the
same as the optical block
equations, which we derived
using a master equation
approach.
OK.
This method is very powerful
for the following reasons.
If you simulate a density
matrix with, you know,
an internal states, or external,
internal states-- I should've
said with in quantum
states, you need
n times n matrix elements,
which can become quite a memory
hog for your computer.
The wave function, at any given
moment, as only n components.
So therefore there is a
computational advantage
in using a stochastic
wave function
approach over simulation
of the density matrix.
The second thing is that a
lot of people, especially
experimentalists, like
sort of this approach,
because it reflects directly
what they do in the experiment.
And I think it's pretty
clear that with this approach
you can deal with a great
variety of situations.
Let me just mention
two obvious extensions.
One is polarization.
A photon is detected.
That means your random number
produced a number epsilon,
which was smaller than delta p.
At that point you can create
a second random number,
which determines if your pull--
if the photon has been detected
with sigma plus, sigma
minus, or pi polarization.
Or you can discuss recoil.
If the photon is-- If
the photon is detected,
you use-- you throw on
another random function
generator, which determines what
the k vector of the photon is.
So what direction each part
k the photon has taken,
and this determines
now what is the recoil,
the change in
momentum of your atom.
So you see, kind
of, you can start
with an atom at 0 momentum.
You can see it emits
a photon, and then
your computer always
makes a choice
based on the random number.
And then you say,
OK my photon has now
received a recoil
kick at 45 degrees.
Now your wave function of
the photon is such and such,
and if you add a laser
to the Hamiltonian,
the recoil may have kicked--
may have Doppler shifted
the resonance, but everything
is easily taken into account.
So you see this quantum
Monte Carlo wave function
method can easily be
extended to describe
external degrees of freedom,
multiple laser fields, and all
that.
Any questions?
OK.
Let me now just
generalize the thought,
but I think you know
already everything about it.
We talked about the
master equation.
We talked about the most
general master equation
in the [INAUDIBLE] platform,
where those operators L
are the jump operators.
And the prominent
example for jump operator
was the signal minus
operator, which
takes a particle from the
excited state to the ground
state.
And this is the jump operator
for spontaneous emission.
But you may have
many jump operators.
May be spontaneous emission
of different photons
with different
polarization and such.
Or the cavity may lose
a photon, and then we
have a jump operator
for the cavity.
We went through that.
Well that means
now in an exact way
that the non-emission
Hamiltonian is
the original Hamiltonian
with an imaginary part, which
comes because of
those jump operators.
And the general quantum Monte
Carlo wave function procedure
is that first you ask,
has something happened?
Has any jump happened?
And this gives you the
probability delta p.
And if-- If no
jump has happened,
you just do a time
evolution with
a non-emission Hamiltonian.
But if a jump has
happened, then the jump
is now-- the wave function is
projected by the jump operator.
If you have a sigma
minus operator,
it takes a particle
to the ground state.
If you have several operators,
a different jump operator
may take your particle
to another state.
And you-- And you then
have a branching ratio
that you know first
a jump has happened.
And then the question is,
which jump has happened?
And you just play the
probabilities game.
So that you see that the quantum
Monte Carlo wave function
method can be immediately
be generalized.
So let me come back
to the special case
of spontaneous emission.
In that case, we have
only one jump operator,
which is sigma minus.
And the normalization is
the square root of gamma.
And that actually means that
our quantum trajectory ground
state, excited state,
is very simple.
If you start with the system
100% in the excited state,
it's very trivial what happens.
Nothing happens.
But if then the jump
occurs, the particle
is in the ground state.
Then nothing happens
then until infinite time.
You then have to start--
The next trajectory
you start in the excited state.
And this time, by chance of
the random number generator,
the jump happens later.
Another time the
jump happens earlier.
And what you then have to
do is, you have to average,
over all of those
realizations, what
is the probability
for the particle
to be in the excited state.
And this is now your estimator
for the excited state diagonal
matrix element of
the density matrix.
And if you-- If you've
written your code correctly,
you will find that you get a
wonderful exponential decay
exactly as you have expected.
Questions?
Now-- Yes?
Let-- Let me now
talk about dephasing.
What I've shown you so far is
how we can unravel the density
matrix in many
microscopic realizations.
And I've given you
a specific example.
We assume probability
for spontaneous emission,
and with that we propagate
our wave function.
But now I come to, sort of,
the nitty gritty details,
or the dirty truth, that what
we have assumed is by no means
unique.
And I want to explain it to
you first by reminding you
of a very, very nice homework
assignment you have solved.
And this was about we have
optical block equations
for the density matrix,
and the dense --
and the solution of the optical
block equation is that we have
population damping
with a damping time t1.
And the off diagonal
matrix elements
are damped with a time t2.
Remember if you've only
spontaneous emission t2
is 2 times t1.
But we can have a lot of
other processes, which
can lead to much,
much faster defacing
time than the population, than
the time of population changes.
And in your homework, you have
discussed three possibilities.
One is, well, spontaneous
emission is energy loss.
But you have discussed three
different possibilities for t2.
One-- Three different
possibilities
how dephasing, loss of
coherence, and phase damping
can happen.
And in this homework
assignment, you assumed either
that there is a random phase,
that the elastic collision
which project onto
the excited state,
and then you got the most
crazy and artificial model.
That every time, randomly,
the phase of the excited state
flips form plus to minus.
So if I would implement that
now, with a quantum Monte Carlo
method, it would have
the following affect.
And I hope you enjoy, sort of,
the graphical representation.
You can really think about
it, that this is what happens.
That this is what inside--
what is inside the density
matrices described
by this process.
So let's assume we
have a system, which
would be in a superposition
of ground and excited state.
And that would mean
that in the left frame
the dipole moment would
just rotate at the resonance
frequency.
It rotates, and it is a
rotating dipole moment,
which emits coherent light.
But now you assume that
you have a random phase.
So if you add
random phases to it,
maybe because you're
fluctuating magnetic fields,
then the line becomes sort
of-- That doesn't look random,
but you know what I mean.
It becomes sort of jagged.
The phase distribution
is still sort of there,
but there is a
jitter on top of it.
And as a result, the light
emitted by this dipole
is spectrally broadened
Well in your second
model you assumed
that-- with a
certain randomness,
with a certain time
constant-- there's
an elastic collision in
the excited state, which
projects the system
into the excited state.
At this moment there is no
superposition state anymore,
and the dipole moment is 0.
So that's what you assume.
Or when you have
random phase flips,
you assumed that
suddenly this kind
of data to data
ministic sine function
suddenly jumps corresponding
to a minus sign in the excited
state.
And depending where
you are in the cycle,
it creates jumps
at random places.
And the question of course is,
if all those three processes--
and that's what you showed
in your homework-- lead
to the same density matrix,
which one is correct?
Which one is real--
is really realized
in an experiment on a
system which is described
by this kind of damping, or
by the optical block equation?
So you can say all or none.
Well you can assume
what you want,
it doesn't make a difference.
And the reason is
actually profound.
The reason-- The reason
is profound in that sense
that the way-- our goal
was to have an open quantum
system, which is the
atomic system, interacting
with a reservoir.
But the way, how we
phrase the question,
we are only interested in
what the atomic system does.
We didn't do extra measurements
on the environment.
The environment was just a dump
for photons; a dump for energy;
a dump for whatever we assumed
in our dephasing mechanism.
So let me just take the
example of putting photons
into the environment.
And this is described by
a certain damping term,
but there is an ambiguity.
And this is shown here.
If you evolve the system-- our,
our atomic system, the density
matrix evolves, but the
environment sort of also
evolves.
And for instance here,
the unitary time evolution
has taken the excitation
from the atom,
and we have emitted a
photon into the environment.
And you remember we got
the optical block equation
by doing the partial trace
here, and just focusing
on the atomic part.
But now wait a moment.
If we trace out
the environment, we
can trace it out in a
different basis set.
Remember, I showed you the
quantum Monte Carlo wave
function, we emit a photon.
But we can, for instance,
detect the photon
in our gedanken experiment.
We can detect it with
linear polarization
or with circular polarization.
If you have a situation where
you have a-- an s state, which
decays to a p state, sigma plus
takes you to m equals plus 1,
sigma minus takes you
to m equals minus 1.
So therefore, if photon is
emitted in you quantum Monte
Carlo procedure, you would
say, now the atom mean
is in the plus 1
state, or now the atom
is in the minus 1 state.
But if you detect
linearly polarized light,
by just putting a
polarizer here--
and this is a unitary
transformation in front
of your detector-- you
would no longer project
the atomic system on
plus 1 at minus 1,
you would project
it on m equals 0
or whatever is connected
to the linear polarization
of the measurement.
So therefore, if
you simply assume
that something has been
dumped in the environment,
and can be used for
measurement, there
are many ways, many
unitary transformations,
what you can do to the
information, to the energy,
to the photons, which have been
dumped into the environment.
And each of them will lead to
a very different trajectory
in your quantum
Monte Carlo system.
So therefore if you
just dump the photons
and not measure them,
you have equal rights
to assume that your quantum
Monte Carlo wave function jumps
to states which correspond
to a circular basis,
or jump to states which
correspond to linear basis.
And there's many,
many possibilities.
But each of those possibilities
is 100% correct unravelling
of the density matrix.
And if you just do it right,
assume that the measurement is
done in a certain basis, and
you're consistent with it,
you will 100% correctly
describe the time evolution
of your atomic system.
Any questions?
Philmore?
AUDIENCE: Again with the dt.
I'm just curious that we take
a [INAUDIBLE] very short,
but why don't you
run into something
like the quantum Zeno effect?
Where if every evolution
is initially quadratic,
like the [INAUDIBLE] frequency,
you take very short dt--
short measuring system--
Shouldn't for a choice
of sufficiently short dt you,
you know the simulation would
give you strange
results, because of--
PROFESSOR: [SIGHS]
AUDIENCE: --some sort of
quantum Zeno effect there?
PROFESSOR: That's a very
deep question, Philmore.
And I, I want to
think about it more,
but I think I've
excluded that by saying
that the time step, dt, is
larger than the correlation
time of the environment.
So I'm doing some kind
of Markov approximation
with the environment, where
s-- the quadratic part
of the behavior
is a coherent time
evolution, for very short time
steps a wave function evolves
quadratically, but this part
is a coherent evolution.
And that's related to the fact
that an atom can emit a photon,
but in the very first
moment, before the vacuum
has transported it away, it
can take the photon back.
And the result of that is
that at very short times
the exponential decay doesn't
start out exponentially,
it starts out a
little bit flatter.
We get the exponential decay,
we get Fermi's golden rule,
and we get optical blocks
equations only if your time
step is larger than
the correlation
time of the reservoir.
And the fact, you remember
when we derived the master
equation we had to say we do
a step, which is sufficiently
small for the dynamics
of the atomic system,
but sufficiently large, that we
are not getting into any memory
affects of the reservoir.
And we've done the
same assumption here.
Other questions?
Nicky?
AUDIENCE: Just confused.
We are not always say
the environment measures
the system in range at
time intervals, delta t,
which are large compared
to the correlation time?
What's more [INAUDIBLE]
the evolution of the atom.
But now everyone isn't
that defected the Markov
approximation we've made when
we derived the master equation?
And I was just wondering
for just-- [INAUDIBLE]
did you derive it by
making the master equation?
Maybe we don't
actually need-- Maybe
we don't need the idea
of constantly measuring.
Maybe a physical interpretation
of the Markov approximation.
PROFESSOR: Oh yes,
exactly, Nicky.
I still think you said it
really very, very nicely.
We derived a master
equation just
by assuming that the system,
you know, takes a photon.
And past the correlation
time, the photon
is taken for good
by the environment.
And with a Markov
approximation, we formalized
that there is no memory
affect, the photon
is not stored like in a cavity.
The photon has disappeared.
And by saying that this
time is very short,
this was a Markov approximation
in the derivation of the master
equation.
But that also means, if
the photon has disappeared,
has separated from
the atomic system,
we are now free to
make a measurement.
And of course it
shouldn't matter
whether we make the
measurement or not.
But what I was able
to do today is,
I was making now the
assumption, let's assume
we make a measurement.
We measure all the photons
which have been emitted,
and the measurement
is probabilistic.
And we fold this
probabilistic evolution
into our quantum system.
And what we obtained was
exactly the same time evolution
for the density matrix as we
got from the master equation.
So in other words,
this should you
that interactions
with an open quantum
system, where irreversibly
energy, photons, angular
momentum, or whatever--
flows into the environment.
Once it has flown
into the environment,
you can measure it.
And you get all the stochastics
from the measurement.
But even if you
don't measure it,
you get exactly the
same stochastics as
if you had measured it.
It's all the same.
Jenny?
AUDIENCE: Now that
I think about it,
it seems sort of weird to me
that we've-- that we're making
these measurements, or
lack of measurements,
these interactions,
at regular intervals.
And not--
PROFESSOR: It doesn't
really matter.
All we-- All we
have to make is--
You could actually make
delta t a random variable.
It wouldn't change anything.
The only thing we
have to make sure
is we have to make the
time interval short enough
that we don't have, maybe, two
photons emitted in that time.
We just want to
make sure that it's
a simple probabilistic
branching, yes or no.
And that's the only
requirement here.
AUDIENCE: Is this a formula
or is it based on time?
You say that would
be the wave function
evolving and then collapse.
And that's-- This is what--
Where the measurement comes in.
The equivalent, so now
say, the equivalent
is a wave function
evolved in a collapse,
when you make a measurement
you say that after it evolves.
So is it possible
that it could also
have-- like evolves
some kind of formalism?
Like this?
Where there is an operator?
Because still like even though
the density matrix operator,
maybe it is kind of like--
[INAUDIBLE] describes a state.
PROFESSOR: I haven't
seen it, Mark,
but I'm absolutely certain
that you could describe
the same physics in
the Heisenberg picture,
where the time evolution
is with operators.
Because what we have here is,
we have a time step, delta t,
where the system evolves as
an isolated quantum system,
and then we measure again.
And so, I think if you
would use operator equation,
you would have an
evolution of the operator
with the same Hamiltonian, which
is non-emission Hamiltonian.
And then the measurement would
do some form of projection.
I have to think about it,
what the projection would
be in terms of operators.
But my gut feeling is, you can
always take the transformation
where you put the time
dependence into the operators,
and not in the wave function.
On the other hand, I have
some little bit misgivings
about that, because the quantum
Monte Carlo wave function
was really developed in order
not to deal with matrices,
not to deal with something
which is dimension n times in,
if n is the number of
components of the wave function.
It was specifically formulated
to have the simpler description
with n coefficients
for the wave function.
But conceptually, I
think, it is evolution
with a Hamiltonian measurement.
Evolution with a
Hamiltonian measurement.
And I assume this could
also be done with operators.
Nancy?
AUDIENCE: Suddenly like
[INAUDIBLE] but when
we've-- these simulations
are actively done,
how important is the randomness?
Like up to epsilon [INAUDIBLE]
because no computer is actually
emitting random numbers.
PROFESSOR: Well I think how
random a random number has
to be is really dealt
with in computer science
and mathematics.
AUDIENCE: But due
to our reserves
we always get this
exponential behavior?
PROFESSOR: I don't
know the answer.
I mean here,
conceptionally, it should
be completely random number.
And I think that algorithms,
which even which produce
pseudo random numbers, but if
the pseudo is close enough,
if there is a recurrence
time of your random number--
if your random number--
your series of random number
repeat itself after several
billion random numbers,
this gives you a
small error bar.
And if you don't-- If you'd
only do a limited sampling,
a limited number of
time trajectories,
I don't think it matters.
Of course if you want to
have ultimate precision,
then also the precision
of the random number
may enter through the
backdoor at some point.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
lack of simulation
of the photons emitted?
But if we know the
photons emitted,
if we have that information,
then we can decide [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: That's correct.
If we-- If we would know--
If we would know more
about the environment,
if we would
say we measured the
photons in a certain basis,
or when energy is dumped
in the environment
by a dephasing mechanism,
we look at the environment.
Then, of course, we would
add extra information to it,
and then certain
quantum trajectories
would reflect the extra
knowledge we have.
And of course, we would
then describe everything
in this basis.
On the other hand,
what you should
learn from this is once the
information, once the photon
has escaped, it doesn't
matter for the time evolution
of your atomic system, in which
basis you measure the photon.
So the evolution of the
atomic system itself--
at least when you averaged--
is unaffected by the basis.
However if you make a
coincidence measurement,
that you say your atoms
which has emitted,
is still flying through
your vacuum chamber,
and now you figure
out the photon
is emitted as circularly
polarized light.
Then of course you know that
this atom, which is still
available, has emitted
circularly polarized light.
And then you have actually
obtained extra information
about your atom.
In other words, the
photon in the atom
was entangled, like a Bell pair.
And if you now do a measurement
on one part of the Bell pair,
you know more about
the other part.
But this is just how
quantum physics works.
If you don't use this
information for anything,
then you could have-- you
could have as well not measured
the polarization.
And it would have no effect
on the atomic density matrix.
OK that's it for today.
We have class at the
usual time on Wednesday.